[Music]  interesting the new Kindle is being sold  at a steep discount in order to undercut  its biggest competitor the iPad okay  well earlier today Amazon released an  even less expensive product not sure  it's gonna work take a look from  amazon.com the people behind the  affordable Kindle Fire and the ultra  affordable Kindle  it's the insanely affordable Amazon  wendel they're doing it for just $5  wendel will show up at your house  whenever you need yeah if I'm free yeah  sure use wendell as an e-reader he blows  very gently on one nipple as his hand  moves to my other nipple  we're games alright you shot the bird  way too high and if he went over the pig  entirely so the pig is just he's just  sitting there  she's still there help with your  homework every single one of your  friends invited you to an improv show  the Amazon Wendell only $5 for 10 bucks  they'll get freaky  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]